from close analysis of the aerial images
investigators calculate the mystery ship
is the same length as the notorious
Russian ghost ship the liubov all ova
deserted in 2013 on its final voyage
from Newfoundland to the Caribbean it
was being towed away for scrap and along
the way the towline broke and now the
ship is floating in the ocean this ship
is rumored to have been taken over by
hordes of cannibal rats I mean there's
nothing else to eat right so imagine
this giant ship full of these ravenous
hordes of cannibal rats appearing on
your local beach right where you live
you what but many doubt the lube of all
OVA could have made it all the way to
California on its own problem is that
the Russian cruise liner was left in the
Atlantic Ocean so unless those rats have
some navigational abilities that people
don't have it would be a pretty amazing
feat for it to get all the way to the
Pacific Ocean and wash up in California
with the aid of the worldview-2
satellite analyst Amanda Marchetti uses
multispectral analysis to further probe
the location I think I can peer through
using the multispectral technology to
actually peer into the water column and
really get a full view of the wreckage
the satellite sensors pick up specific
wavelengths that the human eye can't see
revealing the invisible it's somewhat
intact which means it's probably been
buried for the majority of its time on
this beach but because of the
significant erosion that's occurring
with the El Nino event during this time
period I can easily see that the
wreckage was exposed and now it's
rapidly being buried again before the
sands once again covered the wreck
ground-level examination reveals an
important clue this ship appears to be
made from concrete not steel
when investigators cross-check this
unusual design with records at the San
Diego archives they make a breakthrough
it was one of 12 experimental vessels
built for the u.s. quartermaster Corps
during World War one when steel was in
short supply concrete is heavy but if
molded correctly concrete ships do float
this one stayed in service for just two
years before it was decommissioned and
sold on it turns out this ship is
actually an oil tanker that was taken
over by the mob in the 1930s the mob
isn't interested in oil they renamed the
vessel the SS Monte Carlo and let the
good times roll this ship had it all
when it came to illicit things
it was a floating casino a brothel
and a speakeasy it was a [ __ ] mistake